دخلت محاكمه التفجيرات مطار وميترو بروكسل
في الثاني والعشرين من شهر مارس لعام 2016
جوهره القضيه مع انطلاق تلاوه بيان
الاتهامات والادله في حق المتهمين العشره
في حضور ممثلين اكثر من 900 و40 من
الضحايا وذويهم واصحاب بالحق المدني
موفقه نحو الحقيقه القضائي وسيقول اعضاء
هيئه المحلفين بعد اشهر كلمتهم بشان
المتهمين
ان هم يذنبون ام ابرياء في قفص الاتهام
تسعه من بينهم محمد عبريني صاحب القبعه
الذي تخلى عن حقيبته المفخخه في مطار
بروكسل تاركا وراءه الدماره والهلعه
والقتل الذي احدثه تفجير حقيبتي
الانتحاريين ابراهيم البكراوي ونجيم
العشراوي صباح يوم الثلاثاء 22 من شهر
مارس في الاثناء كان خالد البتراوي قد فجر
حقيبته في العربه الثانيه من مترو محطه
البيك وسط العاصمه خمسه من المتهمين
حكم عليهم
احتجاجا على ما وصفوه بمع كامل مهينه من
قبل قوات الامن رئيسه المحكمه القت
المسؤوليه على وزير الداخليه
[موسيقى]
بوقف المعامله مهينه مثل انحناء المتهم
عاريا امام رجال الامن والموسيقى الصاخبه
هذه الممارسات لا علاقه لها بالمقتضيات
الامنيه هذا السلوك تواصل حتى اليوم
المتهمون عشره تسعه في قفص الاتهام
والمتهم العاشر اسامه عطار متغيب يشتبه في
انه كان المشرف الاول على تفجيرات باريس
وبروكسيل انطلاقا من دير الزهور تردد انه
قتل في غارته مسيره في العام 2017 في
سوريا في رساله صوتيه مؤرخه الحادي
والعشرين من شهر مارس العام 2016 يقول
الانتحاريان نجيم العشراوي وابراهيم
البكراوي الى اسامه عطار المكنى ابو احمد
العراقي والموجود في سوريا يقولون
البيجو بيتحرك المجموعه من دون تاخر لان
افراد المجموعه اصبحوا محاصرين ويفتقدون
مجرد السكن الامن وكانت تحركم في اليوم
الموالي صباح الثلاثاء الاسدي
ردينا الفريق العربي